you talked about a swing back towards
decentralization um
what is the technology revolution that's
going to change the course of humanity
and like what is the impact on financial
markets then well the
and this is a piece that i talked about
at this event i was at this weekend
george gammon's event shout out to rebel
capitalist um
what people are missing and lynn aldon
put out a quote last week to equate
bitcoin and crypto
shows you don't understand either
and so um i use that quote in my talk
and there's a technological revolution
that's happening here but most people
are blinded to it because of the crypto
boom and bust that's been happening but
there's actually a revolution that's
happening so for the first time ever
we've created digital scarcity we've
created true decentralization um we've
been able to now move into the
information age without copying
information
which is like incredibly powerful now
what does that mean we don't really know
when steel was invented it gave us a new
material that we could build skyscrapers
and bridges with it also gave us
material we could build a space shuttle
with but we didn't know that when steel
came out right when electricity came out
the first application was a candle
um it was like a digital camera but
candles were light for five thousand
years what do we need that for but it
gave us the building block to do what
we're doing right now
and so we have a new set of building
blocks we don't know exactly what we
built off of that but i think it's a you
know i would imagine you would agree
it's probably the best risk adjusted
investment that we could make right now
if we're willing to wait so when you use
the electricity example or the steel
example those were building blocks as
you mentioned and in hindsight we know
that okay yes the first applications
were interesting uh but they were
really small compared to what eventually
was possible is the
revolution driven
or like the innovation the blockchain is
it bitcoin as an application of a
blockchain like how do you think through
because i immediately jumped like okay
what would the critics say of uh the
bitcoin only viewpoint they're like yes
of course the blockchain is the
innovation and then we're gonna go put
all these different um you know
applications and it's a building block
and all that how do you think through is
it actually the blockchain or is it the
application of bitcoin that ends up
being like the true innovation that
serves as the foundation for whatever is
to come i believe that the true
innovation is decentralization okay
interesting so how do we achieve
decentralization we achieve
decentralization by instead of having
one database we have multiple databases
in order to achieve that everyone must
be able to run a database
so with bitcoin anyone in a third world
country with a five-year-old laptop can
download the database and run it but you
can't do that with any other of the
other whatever 19 000 coins and so the
the innovation is decentralization
and i believe there's only one that
really gives us that
it's not just decentralization though
right it's like a technology coordinated
decentralization that is operating uh
like my mind jumps to uh belashi
srinivasan whole idea of like you know
these uh cloud-based economies rather
than cloud-based societies where uh
really the decentralization is the
ability to coordinate via technology
across the world in a digital format i
don't think that's it okay explain
biology is super smart by the way so
shout out to him he's he's like a
walking encyclopedia he's insane right
um but i don't think that's it right i
think what it really is is it's it's
decentralization that makes it where
nobody controls
the ledger
it's all about the ledger right if i
have a coin um and i give you the coin
you have the coin if i have the coin i
have the coin but if we do it in an
information age we need a ledger that
shows who has the coin now who controls
the ledger that's the crux of the matter
right so i think the oldest problem that
mankind has had is how do i protect my
property from being stolen so we make a
tribe a village a kingdom a country but
now if nobody can control the ledger
then nobody can steal my asset and if i
want to send it to you nobody can stop
it block and prevent it so digital
coordination is great don't get me wrong
it's going to be massive for production
and things like that and of course when
we have this globalization we can all
collaborate together and we can get more
progress that's awesome that's great but
that that doesn't prevent people from
manipulating the ledger yeah i think
we're saying the exact same thing which
is uh there's only one truly
decentralized uh ledger today right in
terms of the ability to know what i have
is i have and if i send it to you no one
can stop me right right there's a lot
that aspire to do that claim to do it
whatever but there's only one that is
truly decentralized uh when i was
talking about this kind of like cloud
economy or whatever it's just now we
have the ability in a digital format um
if you think of uh bellagi's whole idea
of like there's gonna be three
currencies in the future there's like
the united states dollar uh there's the
chinese and then there's bitcoin yeah
right and it's like one of those three
ends up quote-unquote winning i think
you and i both lean towards well the
decentralized and there'll be many it'll
be many right i mean think about the
dollar took over the reserve currency of
the world from the pound sterling but
that was a 40-year process but the pound
sterling is still being used today it's
really hard to kill currencies right
it's really hard to kill currency so i
think i believe as the world moves to
become more decentralized instead of the
one one reserve currency of the world
everyone's waiting for the final moment
it's decentralized so maybe my reserve
is different maybe microstrategy reserve
is different maybe el salvador reserve
is different but other people use other
things